use this organic cherry tomatoes because
we're going to do a red and green salsa
now what would you what would you
recommend TV with like the dips and the
salsa is like some kind of chip or ship
record like a write up well you know we
love grave corn chips making the salsa
for veggies you know that most
underrated Benji I think is the red
pepper a great organic pepper
it's beautiful holiday red and green so
we've got our tomatillo and our organic
cherry tomatoes in there I'm gonna put
about 1/4 cup of olive oil okay
I'm gonna go ahead and chop some fresh
organic cilantro actually I don't even
have to chop it I'm going in the Vitamix
what am i doing it's not waste I'm gonna
put a little bit of a shallot in here I
might leave it off especially if my kids
are gonna eat it it's not really spicy
but I'll put it in right now and then
how are we on spicy in this group if you
like spicy or not spicy okay so I'll go
okay I'm just gonna do this much of a
jalapeno I don't know what it's going to
do okay so I'm gonna put some live
without
I'm gonna try to make it a little chunky
so it was a half of a life
nice fresh salsa
okay